elles sont désormais jumelles unies par
des liens d'amitié Atar ville maltaise
de 10000 habitants et hencour ont signé
il y a quelques jours l'acte de jumelage
qui officialise leur rochement distante
de 1800 km les deux villes vont pouvoir
ainsi multiplier les échanges culturels
ou sportifs les écoliers également
devraient profiter de ces nouveaux liens
tissés en Europe Malte en plus s'exprime
en langue anglaise et bien entendu c'est
important aussi pour nos jeunes vous
savez qu'ici il y a un système scolaire
très très innovant et bien entendu on a
besoin d'échanger avec la
visioconférence avec tous les nouveaux
moyens scolaires c'est aussi le les
échanges scolaires sont très importants
dans ce ce ce rapprochement bien sûr
avec cette ville de de de l'île de Malte
Atar situé en plein cœur de l'île de
Malte est devenue la 4e ville jumelle
des lancour une nouvelle qui ravie le
maire de la commune à Malte il y a
beaucoup de mairies qui font des
jumelages avec des villes françaises
pour nous c'est notre première fois
etancour est vraiment une belle ville
une grande ville plus grandeatar
d'ailleurs j'espère pouir m rendre pour
mes vacances
personnelles la ville d' abrite
plusieurs sites histori notamment le
palais Saint-Antoine la résidence
officielle du Président de la République
maltaise